las venas varicosas son venas retorcidas
y dilatadas por lo general se presentan
en las piernas las venas varicosas no
suelen ocasionar problemas sin embargo
si le causan dolor o si no le gusta su
aspecto puede que desee buscar un
tratamiento el tratamiento también puede
ayudar a prevenir la formación de
coágulos en caso de que se someta a un
procedimiento quirúrgico en el futuro
como un reemplazo total de cadera
algunos pacientes pueden presentar los
siguientes síntomas piel descolorida
dolor palpitante molestias o calambres
picazón infecciones cutáneas recurrentes
sangrado o úlceras la mayoría de los
casos de venas varicosas puede tratarse
con los siguientes procedimientos
escleroterapia tratamientos
superficiales con láser o dispositivos
microelectrónica y ablación endovenosa
estos procedimientos pueden hacerse en
el consultorio de su médico no requieren
grandes cortes y tienen un periodo de
recuperación corto puede que necesite
más de un tratamiento durante varias
semanas para ver resultados
la escleroterapia funciona mejor en las
venas más pequeñas y las arañas
vasculares en este procedimiento se
inyecta una sustancia química en la vena
la sustancia química irrita y cicatriza
la vena esto hace que la vena se cierre
y se desvanezca
los tratamientos superficiales con láser
o dispositivos microelectrónicos
procedimientos el calor de pequeñas
ráfagas de luz láser o corriente
eléctrica hace que la avena se
desvanezca la fele vector ya también se
utiliza para tratar venas más pequeñas
cerca de la superficie de la piel
durante una plebe comía se hace un
pequeño corte en la piel sobre la vena
luego la avena se extrae y se retira
la ablación endovenosa es un
procedimiento que se utiliza para tratar
las venas varicosas más profundas en
este procedimiento se inserta un tubo
flexible llamado catéter a través de un
pequeño corte en la vena el catéter se
utiliza para enviar el calor proveniente
de la luz láser o las ondas de radio
hacia la vena el calor si era la vena y
hace que se desvanezca
en ocasiones excepcionales su proveedor
de atención médica puede aconsejarle un
procedimiento más invasivo como la
extirpación de la vena por lo general
este procedimiento se realiza en un
hospital y puede requerir más tiempo de
recuperación normalmente se hacen dos o
tres cortes en la piel sobre la vena
dañada luego la avena es atada y
arrancada a través del corte inferior
como con cualquier procedimiento existen
tantos riesgos como beneficios hable con
su proveedor de atención médica para ver
qué tipo de tratamiento de venas
varicosas podría ser el más apropiado
para usted